(audience cheering)
- Well-
- Man, y'all both have like
the rock and roll jackets
going on right now.
I like the rock and roll jackets.
Have you ever met Jeff?
Have you ever met?
- No, I haven't.
- This is the first time we've ever met.
So nice to see you.
- Yeah.
- I like to bring people together.
- You're doing it.
You're doing the thing.
- I have to ask you really,
a professional hockey player.
When did this start?
- I did.
- It just seems an odd thing-
- Very odd for being in the southeast.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, not the traditional
sports down there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My dad, my stepdad was a hockey player.
He grew up in Minnesota.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
- So he sort of just threw me on the ice
at like seven years old and was like-
- That's smart.
- Figure it out.
- Yeah.
- And I fell in love with
falling on my face a lot.
(laughing)
And eight concussions later
and a torn rotator cuff,
I was like this is probably
not the career path for me.
- I think you're supposed
to stop after three-
Concussions.
- That would've been really
good to know at the time,
but I just kept going.
- So did you ever wanna be
anything other than actor?
- No.
No.
No, but my family,
we had a shuffle board
court in our backyard,
so I played a little shuffleboard
and then I was in Stevanker
and I did some curling.
That's all I'll tell you.
- Were you the one-on-one
knee or were you-
- Yes and the brooming.
I did both.
I did the brooming and I did the thing.
- Okay.
- It's the funniest sport to
me just to see someone going-
- Well-
- I was in Italy a couple months back
and I was stuck in the hotel waiting for,
it was a delayed flight
and there was curling on
and it was in Italian
and I was so fascinated.
I was like-
- How random.
- Why is this happening in
Venice, Italy right now?
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Like why am I still watching it.
- I loved it, I loved it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're
like in love with it.
- I was into it.
- Okay so Chase,
do you remember the first time you thought
about being an actor since
you were so into hockey?
Like when did you all of a sudden think
maybe I would do this?
- Yeah so I was in high school
and I did TV production
and I did a lot of the producing,
I was behind the scenes.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- So when I played ice hockey,
I used to have practice
super late at night,
so I wouldn't get home till
like one or two in the morning.
- Yeah.
- And I had this professor
who was a huge hockey fan
so he knew about this career path
that felt very farfetched in Florida.
But he said, you know what,
come in morning announcements
doesn't start for 30 minutes
after the class,
get a little quick cat nap and
then we'll go do the thing.
So I was like, this is the best class.
My GPA was terrible.
And I started making the
commercial segments for the news
and I did this terrible segment about kids
making sure they applied to college,
which the irony of that was
I never applied to college.
(laughing)
So I'm sitting here doing
this commercial segment
and it was-
- Selling people.
- The peak of the Harry Potter stuff.
And so I made this terrible commercial
with like terrible VFX shocking people
with wands about not going to college.
- Sounds fun.
- And my professor was like,
you should get into acting.
- I love that he saw that.
- Yeah with terrible VFX and a wand,
he's like that dude's destined for-
And that was it.
- That is awesome though.
Like I feel like a teacher
is what pushed me to
really have the confidence
to do what I do.
- Mm-hmm.
- I feel like,
did you have a teacher like that that-
- I love the classroom.
Teachers made a big difference in my-
I had some great teachers
and they lifted me way, way up.
- Yeah, me too.
They gave me such confidence.
But Outer Banks is in season three,
so congratulations for-
- Thank you.
(audience cheering & clapping)
- So is it true that you modeled
your character after Kurt Cobain?
- I did, yeah.
- But you're pretty young
to even know Kurt Cobain.
I love that.
- Yeah.
- My stepdad was a DJ.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah so he was,
he heavily influenced me by music.
And I've always kind of,
I don't know about you with characters,
but I always try to make a playlist
with whatever I'm working with on.
- So funny you should say that.
Yes, I have,
and I'm doing it even more now.
Very deliberate playlist and-
- For like mood and-
- It does a lot for me.
- Oh.
- Yeah,
so after the first season,
he's sort of this happy-go-lucky kid
and goes through a little bit of turmoil,
but the second season is really about him
internalizing a lot of that.
So I met with Emmy,
our costume director,
and she and I sort of sat down and said,
okay this is the direction we're going,
what are your thoughts?
And I was listening to a
lot of Nirvana at the time,
sort of building the character in my head.
And I said, Kurt Cobain,
like let's do big flannels.
Let's do things that
are out of the ordinary
for where he normally is.
And so, and sort of modeled
the imagery of the character-
- [Kelly] The aesthetic of it, yeah.
- With the dialogue in
the script going forward.
So you're seeing the transition from,
I'm excited about this
world of chasing treasure,
to I miss my father and I don't know
if I'm doing my friend's justice.
So we kind of played
with the visual imagery
as much as we did to storyline itself so-
- That's cool.
I like how much you think
about the character.
Nobody, I never think about that
when I'm watching something.
I never think about all the backstory
that goes into it or the
reasons like why you do so
and the fact that you make playlists.
That's cool.
Yeah, it's fun.
I think it's a fun time.
- Yeah.
I wanna hear your playlist
for your characters.